let's sort of start off with the liver
King thing because
um back in December uh Derek from more
plates more dates put out a pretty
compelling video and I I kind of figured
out pretty quickly and I saw that the
Reddit threads do as well and yeah you
were like the source of the original
email when he was he was basically
trying to connect with somebody to sort
of help him grow his business like he
made it very very clear in the email
that he wanted to blow up his business
and get lots of views and he needed to
sort of like have the look as well which
is what he sort of developed with his
physique but he lied about his physique
and and continuously when he was probe
and asked that he was always natural
um when did he hit you up with that
email by the way
so that was about one and a half years
ago I think there was the second or
third email that we had because we had a
consultation prior and
um during that consultation he basically
portrayed himself as a very successful
guy you know usually a guy that I prefer
to work with at that time for coaching
so that was one of the last clients I
actually accepted as a coaching client
um then it took a little while for us to
get started because he was busy and I'm
quite busy at the time also and then I
sent him a questionnaire that was all
right forget me if the dates are wrong I
mean it's been such a long time I think
it was like May or April
2021 give or take
and you filled it out also that took a
while and then we started working
together a couple weeks later
and I saw a ton of red flags
um so I decided to let him go and then
you know you see him get more popular
and more popular basically everything
that he said that he wanted to do in
that email he actually accomplished you
know a million subscribers or followers
by May 2022 which was last year and
that's quite commendable but the way he
did it
um you know it was based on kind of a
false premise
yeah there's a lot of deception so like
what were the red flags early on for you
when you sort of took them on you know
for a console so so I still don't want
to go too much in depth uh because
there's a lot more to be said but it
could just hurt the guy further and the
old idea Beyond releasing these emails
was for him to come clean and end the
line right so he could give him a little
bit of incentive to finally come clean
and then you know address the situation
after lying through his teeth about that
for one and a half years I did an
audience so
I just saw a couple red flags in it for
people that coach or do mentorships that
would say yeah yeah that you know okay
so
I decided to
um when I took them on I figured you
know what the blood work okay it's not
perfect but I think it can fix it right
with time
um you know the diets it's not perfect
but I feel I can you know
show some improvements to make him
healthier
and um after two or three weeks of
miscommunication and then him saying
that he didn't want to make those
changes or do further testing regarding
organ Imaging or blood work you know I
figured I know exactly where this is
going to go I've coached bodybuilders
for over a decade
and when I see that the reluctancy to
take care of your health
it's just not something that I enjoy
working with you know so I refunded him
now he says that I didn't refund him
which I'm not sure if that's a tactic to
get me to release a PayPal statement
with this full address because that's
even worse than releasing emails it's
basically doxing a guy so I'm not sure
if that's a tactic but I'm 100 sure that
I refunded this guy
um and otherwise I wouldn't understand
why somebody would wait one and a half
years to bring that up
I will why would you yeah that must have
been hard to sit on your fingers during
that time like not saying anything you
know seeing him on on podcasts oh yeah
I'm totally Natty I've never touched
this stuff never would touch you know
with the hand up in the air like this
yeah right
yes it was it was pretty honestly it was
painful right and the position the guy
wanted to put me and basically he wanted
to keep he you know in the background
which I don't mind I have Shadow coach
people and help people that are known or
or competed the world championships with
their subject to drug testing I helped
them beat the drug sets and everything
but those guys don't go around
pretending to be natural and and sell
um image yeah yeah supplements that are
that are you know an image that is
unobtainable without just take this
capsule of like a beef liver or
something and you'll look like me is
basically what he's you know purporting
yeah basically yeah so those those guys
that I help
um they don't have to worry about
anything because they're not
disingenuous but this guy you know he
goes in a Mark Bell podcast and he uh
you know for hours he tries to convince
him that he's natural to the point Mark
Bell actually believed him and I felt
bad for the guy
can't believe this you know
so so Derek got some evidence and I got
some evidence we talked about this for
quite some time and after a while it
just had enough I'm just like you know
what this this needs to end give this
guy an opportunity to come clean
um and then get started on the
documentary so I gave him permission to
use those emails in a redacted form and
those are two emails out of
at 25 000 if not more that I've received
over the last 10 to 50 years that I've
been trying to help people so a lot of
people went right quite hard on me right
for the last month six weeks that oh you
should never release those emails and
you know for the other
you know hundreds of people that I've
helped that would never happen because
they were not disingenuous so people say
that you know I'm a leaker in the stitch
in a rat and this and that but
somebody has to be The Whistleblower in
this case and I was part of it uh but of
course as the former coach for two or
three weeks you're the one that gets the
most fire out of it so anyway he gave I
gave Derek permission to release it and
then well people knew within four to
five days that uh it was my email
yeah it's amazing how people like like
over invest in like these ideas and
these emotions and these ego Investments
like how could you betray somebody like
the guy's a piece of [__] like he like
it's it's I mean it was clear to me from
the get-go people ask me you know when
he started to rise and fame when I was
doing Q and A's or podcasts like every
once in a while somebody would comment
call and be like you know what do you
think of this liver King guy you know I
think he's Natty and I'd look at him I'd
be like are you kidding me like the
vascularity the size of the veins are
like ropes going down his arms he's huge
you know for like in your 40s it's
impossible for your nuts to produce that
that amount of testosterone like you'd
have to be I've never seen it in my life
and I've seen some very good drug-free
athletes yeah some phenomenal directly
athletes who didn't even look close to
him so everybody in the bodybuilding
Community everybody with a brain knew
everybody would have brain knew
um so what I realized now is that
basically I tried to better the the will
the well-being of the general population
and
um are you still there okay yeah yeah
okay okay so I tried to basically better
the well-being of the general population
to make them understand that this is not
possible without steroids and the guy's
lying to you guys and it was exactly the
general population that hated me for it
but it was the bodybuilding community
and the people that you know knew
exactly what was going on that
understood you know what this is just
another charlatan that's going to come
rise and fall within one or two years
and that's part of the fitness industry
right I know so I was yeah it was a very
particular situation I thought about it
very very long and carefully for
over a year
and at one point I just saw that the guy
tried to undo a lot of our hard work you
know to educate men on what you should
do and that's being healthy and and
doing your blood work and brushing your
teeth and wiping your ass
um yeah so um you know whatever happened
to the blood Labs there was there was
indication and Derek's video that um
there's more coming with blood Labs so
they had a conversation and uh on
request that blood work will not be
released for now yeah so that was a
friendly conversation
um and then he still cheated on me but
I understand you know it's okay
um
I made it I made a redact uh reduction
on my statement right because I wanted
to wait what his statement was going to
be and then when I watched his statement
I'm like
dude I should have released this like
over a year ago when he just got started
with this nonsense
um you know then it would have saved a
lot of people a lot of Heartache now
uh but yeah I mean you know as a former
coach you feel a little bit conflicted
about it
so when I started apology video I made
my statement but then based on the
discussion he and Derek had it was a
friendly discussion as far as I know I
redacted another 10 to 12 minutes
um not to aggravate the situation any
further
um just to make people understand why I
did what I did
and uh yeah that video went quite viral
for my channel 150 000 views
um and that was the end of it then I
went on holiday and then I you know I
was wondering if I was going to meet the
guy at the Mr Olympia or not but he
didn't show up and nobody actually
nobody did yeah I don't know I mean
usually when this guy's like for Our
Generation if there's drama you you
would like to have a conversation right
yeah
um or maybe I don't know I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out